[Music]
and welcome back everybody to another
episode of the careful boys where we
keep it careful here almost always
always you know
so uh let's let's have fun let's do
another little prom let's ask a question
okay okay and everybody go around share
a little bit of a story but uh we were
just talking about how everybody here
used to ditch school
let's hear some of the reasons for why
some of y'all were leaving school
ryan you got an excuse
dude i just i just hopped the fence and
walked off i feel like joe needed a
reason to go to class yeah yeah i i grew
up really close to my middle school in
high school so i could walk home don't
you start your house like every day like
[ __ ] i just want to go home well i'm
going to tell this girl
i could never use the bathroom like i
could never take [ __ ] in school like
everything about bathrooms yeah of
course oh like it just gets locked up
like i just can't go it's like too dirty
i'm just like whatever i'm like this is
whatever some people are like when they
travel too yeah like i have a hard time
going to the bathroom so i used to call
my mom
and be like yo mom i gotta take [ __ ] and
she used to call in and be like he's got
a doctor's appointment oh she backed you
up yeah
then i'm home i'm like i'll have lunch
like whatever and then i'd walk back to
school then you went back to school
that's the [ __ ] sicky [ __ ] ever yeah
cause i'm like yeah whatever
what because
you want to stay home and just watch tv
and just say like no because like then i
would get in trouble because my parents
would know because then my teachers
would know so it was just like you know
it was the unwritten rules i could do
that as long as i went back to school
dude i [ __ ] gave myself pneumonia bro
so i didn't have to go to school for a
couple of weeks
you gave me you gave yourself pneumonia
really yeah
what would you do
i wield it i was like every day
you know how they say like in the
[ __ ] secret right you gotta like ask
and manifest right every [ __ ] morning
i was like oh i'm so sick i i i believe
it i believe i'm so sick right and
they're like you ain't [ __ ] sick get
your ass to [ __ ] school right and i'm
like i swear to god and i rat i would
run to the kitchen try to boil some
water put the thermometer in that [ __ ]
and i'm [ __ ] pull it back out i'm
like you see mom i'm sick as [ __ ] and
then every day i wasn't sick till one
day i started coughing like a
[ __ ] right like yes
they took me to the emergency room at
like three in the morning it was pretty
nuts i was hooked up to ivs and i was
like [ __ ] yeah
i see it believe it achieve it i i tried
to do that once when zelda came out
majora's mask i was like i'm sick i'm
sick
and i remember i i like wheeled myself
to a temperature of 99 but really i
think i was just holding my breath
so it was like sweating and it got up to
99 cause i also tried the thermometer
trick yeah put the thermometer in
boiling water it got too hot yeah it got
too hot it broke 200. it broke and then
all the mercury came out and then like
solidified and i was like oh [ __ ]
i was like well that there goes that i
probably caught a sickness you know from
one of the students or whatever but i
remember being out for like weeks and i
was like yo this is a [ __ ] dope
racket man like i'm gonna try to get
sick some more and i remember one time i
had this like stomach flu thing and then
i had to go to the uh to get a what do
you call it the [ __ ] cat scan [ __ ]
and then i actually had a piece of [ __ ]
stuck in my intestines yeah the
ultrasound so i was like dude this is
the best gig in the world like i feel
like [ __ ] but i could watch tv i get
taken care of i'm like i am the best
kind of milker but that sounds like a
nightmare to me because you were
constipated and that's all i can do it
[ __ ] hurts
i'm like dude i'm like this is the
opposite of what i want he ditches to
[ __ ] but you know what i didn't have to
go to school and and then at a certain
point i'll be like oh i think i'm
feeling better i need to go hang out
with my friends and then they're like
all right [ __ ] it just do whatever you
want so i get to play every [ __ ] day
oh my gosh when you when you're like on
the verge of death your parents are
afraid that they're going to lose you
right so they're like you gotta exploit
that you gotta exploit that [ __ ] and
then you get to play as much as you can
i love how nonchalant he just yeah you
know your parents are like you know
afraid they're gonna lose you so
if there was anything wrong with me
there was two there was two solutions it
was toast
or take some advil like that was it
like you didn't have the robitussin for
everything no it was it was toaster like
it was advil and toast and your parents
are doctors yeah no they don't give a
[ __ ] people who have uh you know
parents who are doctors or in the
medical field they definitely
pay less attention to your medical
issues
and because they've seen that at all
they usually say stop being a [ __ ] yeah
basically they're just like you know
like fine i could have a bloody nose my
dad's like you know whatever
like take eat some toast
was it wheat or was it white no it was
white bread bro this was in the 90s like
wheat bread wasn't a thing yeah
if you wanted wheat bread you had to pay
like 400 dollars
and hire a baker bart or something like
there was no wheat buyer a bakery yeah
did your parents pick yourself or did
your guys mom have like a split
personality disorder where like when uh
like when you're normal right she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but then the minute you're
sick she's like the best nurse in the
world you mean she was your mom
she was everyone like normally she
all of a sudden she got like this
[ __ ] hot soup with [ __ ] dates and
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah
like towel on my phone with the goji
berries in there yeah and if she comes
are you okay and [ __ ] puts a pillow
underneath my feet i'm like damn you
were a [ __ ] [ __ ] yesterday
you just say that to her
heart was the worst kid ever dude
this guy was such an [ __ ] he's
terrorizing
i'm so confused because yesterday you
were [ __ ]
because i was playing hooky at [ __ ]
ethan allen
i'll get you massaging my head every day
what the [ __ ] is this
you're a terrible mom
i would uh sometime
i really actually rarely ditched uh in
high school because i was able to just
get like off periods like during lunch
and break and stuff so i was already
good with that but i remember having my
sister
uh
pretend to be my parents and like write
a letter and like signed it as if it was
like a parental note that i had like to
do stuff but i could only pull it off
like once or twice you know what i mean
um and then from there i'll
[ __ ] just go play magic the gathering
wow varsity varsity magic together
i will say when it came to college
though
disney class
was way different scale because if you
didn't have to take attendance in the
class i never showed up yeah
literally especially if notes are online
there's like 300 kids
i'm never going to show up to a lecture
hall like you're just going to fall
asleep anyway you're just going to be on
your t-mobile sidekick anyway
you know what i'm saying so it's like
never went to class
never and still got bees hey yo let's go
dude so you're so you're a failure in
the asian eyes is what you're saying
with your being well i already had a
sister who was doing better so no matter
what i failed no matter what you were in
the shadows yeah my shit's highly
opposite um i never ditched school in
high school whatsoever i was like really
good at that and then um
i but i didn't get good grades so i had
to go to community college and i was
going cerritos college
and uh it was like spring break you know
spring break you get like a week off so
i just hung out at my homies house a
whole week played video games
and then once it was over i went back to
um my first class at cerritos college
and then they were like oh spring break
just started now
you were one of those guys
were you just blazed out of your mind
you said no [ __ ] clothes dude you
took a week off before the kitchen
stopped that semester
because of that i flunked the entire
semester oh all 12 units
gone
over that so you missed the final
everything no i just missed too much
class that they just w'd me because they
were like you didn't show up for us
weeks straight yeah but you could have
been like i was really sick
after the video
but there's just like community college
like a weirder thing where they just
assume you [ __ ] gave up like half the
class does every class oh that's true
though because the first week of school
it's a full campus but by the end of the
semester nobody's there
yeah there's always like four people at
the end of the like thing because it's
like a purgatory you're basically trying
to fight
this is the step before hell like
welcome just battle royalty right so
yeah that whole semester was just gone i
was just like oh that's halfway through
and now i got nothing to do community
college is like that it's a full class
and by the end it's like five students
like to retake everyone's classes
halfway in
and then by then there's another edition
of the book you got to rebuy that [ __ ]
oh
the scam i'm a college textbook buying
books bro unintentional ditch story that
everybody was like
you're a [ __ ] idiot
i used to try to ditch kumon all the
time
it's the most asian thing i've ever
heard
i want to ditch cool i just like now if
you look at the logo of kumon it's just
a child's face with like just a straight
neutral he's not even happy he's not
even happy he's not sad he's void of
personality
math it's like lobotomy they've
lobotomized the kumon how long would did
you go to kumon for like two or three
years was kumon boring yeah it was
here's the thing
my parents would only get involved with
my schoolwork if i was doing bad
so i was never bad
but
like you know it was a traditional
indian kid i was like all in ap classes
and like i just didn't want to do the
extra [ __ ] homework today's video is
brought to you by upstart think of all
the things that you could be doing right
now if you didn't have high interest
loans or credit card debt well upstart
can help you make those dreams a reality
by helping you pay off that debt quickly
and easily upstart is the fast and easy
way that you can pay off your debt with
a personal loan all online or funding
personal expenses over half a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment upstart knows
you're more than just your credit score
and is expanding access
to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart uses your income and
current employment to help you find a
smarter rate for your loan with a five
minute rate check you could see your
rate up front for loans of 1 000 to up
to 50 000
and receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
wow find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today by going to
upstart.com
off the record don't forget to use the
url below so they know that we sent you
upstart.com off the record your loan
amount will be determined by your credit
your income and other certain
information that you put on the loan
application make sure you go to
upstart.com off the record and i'm like
why do we have extra homework like i
just don't want to do it
so one time i think i was like in eighth
grade sixth seventh or eighth grade we
were going and i just didn't do any of
it like i didn't do the packets my dad
would
like hide an answer key
we went to kumon i brought in my bag
like a bottle of coke and ritz crackers
and like you have to take the placement
exam like after every grade you take an
exam to get you to the next level
i gargled
the coke in my mouth with the ritz
crackers and then i pretend to throw up
everywhere that's so [ __ ] scary
i don't know if my dad remembers his
story
and then he was like my dad i know in
his head he was probably like what the
[ __ ] my son said
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
he was like i guarantee my dad was like
he did all this to get out of a goddamn
math test he must [ __ ] hate this [ __ ]
and then finally he was just like oh you
don't need to go yeah because i was like
this
i think once that was a waste of my
money exactly like in hindsight if i
were if i wasn't my son did that
i've been like dude what the [ __ ] what's
wrong with you man yeah and that's when
you became an actor yeah and then i was
like well i knew i wanted to be an actor
in sixth grade
and so my parents gave up hope i think
on all of my academic dreams around like
eighth or ninth grade
dance i used to go to sylvan learning
center you know what that yeah yeah yeah
yeah the white kumon basically what's
that like over there what's the
difference it's uh it's always in a mall
and then you you depending on how well
you do at the tuning session you get
gift certificates to mall stores what
positive reinforcement that's so much
better all i would get was just like
congratulations here's a more difficult
exam they would give you like they would
give you like an electronics boutique
like gift certificate yeah dude
i was sick but then they also were
really really bad teachers
like so you really didn't [ __ ] learn
anything so they just give you coupons
and you're like [ __ ] yeah yeah [ __ ] it's
like it's almost like a
it's almost like a handshake thing where
the teacher is like hey you know like
just act like you learned a lot so your
parents continue to pay for this akuma
and everyone was a [ __ ] human abacus
but yeah because you're not allowed to
use calculators they had the english
portion but i honestly don't even
remember that because that was like
reading comprehension and grammar and
so as long as you just physically read
it you're like oh i can figure this out
but the math was like if you didn't know
how to do it you didn't know how to do
it yeah because you didn't have a
calculator i remember going to kumon for
like two classes and then my mom pulled
me out because she found out they don't
hit the kids there that sounds about
right that sounds about right she's all
like wait they don't [ __ ] him up she's
like if he doesn't go what am i paying
for
he doesn't do the work you don't hit him
like we're not going there
she's like man i can't find a quality
place with child abuse man
america man it's getting soft see that's
why like my parents put me in martial
arts because like if i got in trouble
they'd be like you're doing 25 push-ups
so you imagine like a five-year-old
skinny indian kid who can barely stand
up and hold his body weight like they're
like no on your knuckles
i'm like five yeah i'm five years old
you know what i mean and my indian
parents are like
yeah
and all the white parents are like
what's going on
i miss that type of discipline what
about you uh nick you ever [ __ ]
dis you know i mean not really i do
remember this one story because i was i
played sports in high school not any
cool sports but i played water polo and
i swam that's cool
anyway so i would always leave at like
eighth period for games so i would leave
and all that [ __ ] right eighth period
eight period yeah is that your last
period that was like like seventh and
eighth we would leave what the [ __ ] is
seven
so yeah i don't know we would just get
to leave early seventh period and
honestly that was the reason why i
played sports so i was like we get to
leave early okay
how long were the classes 10 minutes it
was 55 minutes actually in our high
school mine was similar did you get out
of school at five that feels long like
we would start it was funny we would
start our day on second period
weird our first class of the day was
always second period anyways this
doesn't matter this is not important no
we like all these intimacies wait it
started at second so i really want to
know how your school system works
where'd you grow up i went to pasadena
high school okay so it was uh it was
like a zero period or something home
room home room yeah pretty much but we
didn't get to go to that i was for like
the extracurricular whatever anyway so
seven days period we would leave and you
would usually have out my seventh period
was a physics class and my eighth period
was my sport class for whatever reason
so when i would leave to go to the games
i guess my teachers would just mark me
absent and at the end of the year my
senior year
they started sending like uh progress
reports of everyone's attendance because
ditching was a very popular thing in my
school it was like probably the most
common
issue it's pretty popular in a lot of
stuff exactly
but like
like it was it was like really bad it
was like i don't know epidemic it was it
was a pandemic bro
it was a ditch democrat yeah
pasadena baby kids would get arrested
and [ __ ] like it was like a whole
[ __ ] thing anyway it doesn't matter
um so
i got a notice in the mail from the
school saying i had 65 absences for the
whole year oh [ __ ] whoa but like that
was considering for one period one
period would be in absence right
everyone else all my other friends that
would ditch all the time they were like
the 200s
for periods that they would miss wow and
i don't know i've never seen my dad
to this day
so mad at me ever in my life like he was
like i can't believe you've been
ditching class like this
i can't believe this he's like i am so
disappointed oh it's over i cannot
believe you and i was like that like
it's only because it's the sports
classes everyone else has
over 200 absences and he goes i don't
care about the other kids yeah of course
and i was like is this [ __ ] guy
giving me [ __ ] for this right now you're
like you see how wide my back is like
you see i'm [ __ ] water i'll throw a
ball at your head 45 miles i'm 115
pounds i can kick your [ __ ] ass sir
how dare you i mean while he's like
yeah
is he pulling out the belt he's like
that's a water ball these swimmers bro i
don't know why they they would always
slap their bicep against their lat and
it was like the coolest [ __ ] thing i
don't know why but i was like why do
they do that cause they're lame dude
okay but anyways my parents got they've
nev i've done way worse [ __ ] in my life
i've come home smell like pot
just wreaking a pot my dad wasn't even
mad at me at all but when i ditched 60
classes for the whole year he was like i
can't irresponsible how many times this
is [ __ ] have you guys gotten detention i
was like this kind of oh
[ __ ] i got attention for fighting when i
was like in middle school and i was like
junior high and cheating
probably every single day for both
seventh grade and eighth grade dude i
got saturday school because of that [ __ ]
yeah i got saturday school couples i got
banned from taking math at my high
school
how'd you get banned from learning
you got banned from learning because i
talked [ __ ] about the [ __ ] quadratic
equation or something like how do you i
mean
you got cancelled no it's the dumbest
it's the dumbest thing like this um you
know you every [ __ ] time you like
when you when you get to algebra you
just have that moment maybe you didn't
but like you get that moment where
you're like when are we gonna [ __ ]
use this
like oh absolutely yeah we're still
there i don't even remember algebra and
it's so like i was just very [ __ ]
loud mouth about it and then uh the
teacher was like you are gonna use this
and it was right when all the numbers
were gone and it was nothing but letters
and it was like l x over d whatever it
solved for d or whatever and i was like
when the [ __ ] is this ever gonna i
didn't say [ __ ] but i was like what okay
am i gonna end up at ralph so they're
gonna go your total comes to eight x
over x v that's the right answer though
and then she was like get out and then
she was like i'm never gonna teach you
in this school so they they let me uh
they made me not take math i had to go
to a different school for just math she
[ __ ] refused the right to give you
service
yeah well i have a question how many
times have you used the quadratic
equation post that man only in math
class
wait i think she's [ __ ] up for that
she's [ __ ] up and [ __ ] her because she
sucks and she sent me down a spiral of
thinking i wasn't good at math
because like
she was a shitty ass teacher yeah and
then so what happened is i had to take a
math class at don bosco tech which is
like a catholic all-boys school for real
and i was like the bully there and i
made these kids [ __ ] cheat for me for
three years wow
and i got all the way to like trig and i
didn't know one [ __ ] thing about math
oh that's how you do it so then when it
came to entrance exams for colleges i
[ __ ] massively failed the math
portion even though i was in like pretty
good math classes
and then uh i believed i sucked at it up
until cyprus community college and then
i was getting all a's and i was like
holy [ __ ] math is [ __ ] dope she
explains the world man that was freshman
year that was my first [ __ ] month
taking algebra one
and because i mouthed off she banned me
from math that [ __ ] crazy yo this is
hey what's his teacher's name uh miss
dumbass
her name's miss silau
she was filipino too she [ __ ] had my
back my ap chem teacher mr langella he's
out there ap cam you're smart bro
he probably just became in third grade
or some [ __ ] dude uh i was in 10th grade
he had a bet with me which he definitely
has lost he said hundred dollars that i
wasn't going to go into the arts that i
would fall back why would he want to bet
you though
he's going to be eating oh yeah 100 he's
being racist but he doesn't know
that i got a movie coming out in
six hours
[Laughter]
what's that teacher's name mr langella
mr langella i bet he would trip the [ __ ]
out if he knew you were the voice of ken
he was i will say this he was he was he
was always good he was always a good guy
yeah but i think i think secretly he did
it to motivate me that's what i would
like to believe oh dude that's why
awesome
he because he was also the football he
was a football coach yeah and i i don't
know i think he saw me in the show once
or twice i mean who knows i played the
[ __ ] place i told you what you needed
to hear yeah that's what i always think
it's missing but like no matter what it
doesn't matter everyone's gonna be a
hater she actually did spin me into like
because of that i did find dance
all day wow uh you know dancing wasn't
allowed in seventh-day adventist schools
but then when i had to go to that
all-boys school that's when i got into
dancing that's when i met other b-boys
and then that was my first b-boy crew
was the guys at that she's the wow dude
yeah
everything happens for a reason and she
sees the algebra of life but [ __ ] the
quadratic equation that was the worst
one that's the worst one
[Music]
you